このストーリー気に入られた方々はなんで気に入られたかというストーリーっていうのは全部この日本語になっても英語になっても省略バージョンなんですよ
で 注釈書ではそのまま日本訳訳してみると面白くないんです
かなり長いんですね これは
で ある花屋さんがいてね
えーと それでこの花屋さんはこの王様にあの花を運ぶ仕事で
あの 他仕事はしないんですね
かなりお金もらっていたみたいですね
毎日毎日 金貨で八 八コですね
一日でこれね 小判八で花買うってかなり相当な花の色
まあ宮殿に運ぶものだからね
彼がものすごい大きなでっかい会社でしたでしょうね
いろんな人々から花を集めて集めて
毎日宮殿に運ぶ それであるお釈迦様托鉢に出ているのを見たら
もう何か喜んじゃって
もうお釈迦様に何かふさわしいオファーも何か尊敬しなくちゃいけないんだということで
本人がまあ やっぱり花をお供えした方がいいんじゃないかなと
言ったっても自分にはもう人に売る花もないんです
もうそこはもう一般人とは商売もやらない
もう王様だけで 王様は他のところはお花買ったりするのめんどくさい
そこで契約して ずっとそちらからもう毎日花を運んでくれる
でもこの花はもうどうしようもないんだと
これはもう契約してますから
王様に宮殿に花を運ばなくちゃいけないし
自分が花持っていけなかったらもう花なくなっちゃいますから
宮殿の仕事は成り立たなくなっちゃうんですね
で 彼が考えて まあいいや
そんなのはと 一日はもうあの小判八枚でしょうにと
八枚返せと言ったら それは返せますし
そこで終わりませんだから契約違反したんだから
まあ自分はもう逮捕されるし
もしかするとあの処刑にする可能性もある
しかし やっぱり本人が花を差し上げたいと
何かしたいんですね 何かしたいんです
この場ではもう花しかないし
花を差し上げるしかないし
花はあげられません それでもその人はもうまあいいや
もう王様に殺されたって言ったことない
こんないいことは思い
思い出したらいいことはもうまた二度とチャンスが来ないかもしれません
だからもう差し上げますということで
全部花をお釈迦様に差し上げるんですね
そんな話ですけどね そこでこの自分の命まで捨てたということでね
良いことだと決めたら
良いことだとハッキリしたら
もう振り向くことはしませんという
そういうことを言いたがってるんですよ
自分が行うことが良いことであると
しっかりと公式に合わせたところで
もう良いという結果が出たら
またもう振り向いたり
また考え直したりとかとんでもないんだと
しっかりまっすぐ行動すること
それだったら死ぬんではないかと
そんなことだったら人間に何もできないんですよ
だから 俗世間でもいろんなすごいことをやってる人々は
もう死ぬのは怖いとかね
痛いのは嫌とかね そんな間抜けな人間じゃないんでしょうに
このプロボクサーとかボクシングやってる人々でもね
レスリングやってる人々でもね
ものすごい怪我人になってもね
体壊れて障害 になってももう気にしない
もうそれやるんでしょうに
それでまあ上手な人はいろいろそれでベルトを取ったりはする
来る人はまあ途中で負けたりもする
まあ途中で負けても怪我してね
まあスポーツも二度とできない状態になっても
別にそれでやらなかった方がよかった
やらなかった方がよかったということはないでしょうね
だからやっぱり人間っていうのは
まあいいことだと分かったものは
もうとことんもう振り向くことをしないでやるべきなんです
やり出したら結果出すまでやると
途中で腰上げる世界は仏教ではありません
やってみなきゃわからんっていうのは
こんな それもまた腰抜け考え方でいい加減で無知な考え方なんです
やってみなきゃわからんじゃなくて
やる前にどんな結果になるのか調べなさいよというそちら辺をしっかり出ています
で まあそういうところも
まあ仏教の世界ではいくつかのポイントは俗世間とは違いますと覚えておいてください
話は終わりです  [終始音楽]